70 years the longest reign of any
British monarch
and it is hard to think of another
period where the country has changed
quite so much culturally socially
economically and one of the best ways of
seeing those changes over time is
through charts Let me Give an example
over the Queen's Reign the UK population
grew by 17 million but that rise
actually happened in two stages or ages
and These Bars show you population
growth so anything above the line is the
population growing in the 50s and 60s
look you can see a big increase in UK
born members of the population that's
those the black bars but now I'm going
to bring on the impact of migration look
these lighter purple bars they show
people leaving the country on mass in
the 60s and the 70s that was the brain
drain and from the noises onwards look
you can see it is most of the population
growth comes from immigration that
really shows you a massive shift or
another way of looking at the same story
if you look at the number of children
born on average to each woman the total
fertility rate in 1952 it was 2.2
children per woman look at that line
there then that goes up that's the baby
boom there you can see about three
children per woman but today it's come
all the way down to 1.6 children per
woman that's the lowest level on record
and well below the replacement rate that
dotted line there that's the rate at
which the population can sustain its
size in the long run without immigration
what about this ladies for cutting bread
in a hurry when those hungry youngsters
come in for tea the upshot is this
country's complexion has changed as to
have our lives both at home and in the
workplace for men and particularly for
women
consider back in 1952 the female
participation rate women in employment
was just 40 percent look at that line
there but by the 2020s look at it going
up you can see it had risen to over 74
that was a dramatic change in the
workplace meanwhile the percentage of
men in employment look I'll bring that
line on you can see that Line's actually
fallen down for 95 percent to 84 percent
after 19 years we're free again well
you're glad co-wrestling's over yes why
because customers can have more there'd
be plenty of work for us
and the nature of jobs has changed too
look this shows you where people work
and you can see in the 1950s about 47 of
people worked in primary and secondary
jobs this is getting stuffs out of the
ground or making things with that stuff
by the early 2000s look at how things
have changed it's down to 16 more than
80 percent of us work in that light
purple segment Services these are Big
shifts but we're just scratching the
surface it's hard to think of another
period where the country and economy has
changed quite so much this story is
sometimes told as a tale of decline but
I think that's oversimplification have a
look at of all the measures perhaps the
most important when it comes to how well
off we are this is GDP per capita and
have a look at how this has changed it's
measured in dollars so that we can
compare it with across different
countries around the world and the UK
look there it is in 1952 compared with
the rest of the leading industrialized
Nations the UK was upper middle of that
pack but look at what happened then all
countries got better off over time look
at the bars they're all going up so
everyone's getting better off but the UK
is getting better off slightly less
quickly than the rest so it fell down on
that particular leaderboard but got
considerably wealthier at the same time
is that decline maybe but one place you
can certainly see decline is the value
of the currency the pound sterling which
of course bore the Queen's image versus
a basket of other currencies the pound
has weakened considerably since 1952 one
devaluation after another from the pound
in your pocket Wilson moment of 1967
through to the IMF bailout of 1976
you've got black Wednesday in 1992 the
financial crisis uh in 2008 and of
course the EU referendum each of these
seismic moments pushing the pound
gradually weaker
we have been warned but smoke still
comes from manufactory chimneys while
from the open fires of houses the evil
Paws in even greater volume
something else happened too it's easy to
forget that as the queen began her Reign
this industrial Powerhouse was still
pumping out vast quantities of sulfur
and carbon into the skies as it
de-industrialized that began to change
for evidence consider where we got our
power from electricity back in 1952 look
you can see the components of where our
electricity comes from 1952 there's coal
96 of our power came from burning coal
but just look over time about how that
has changed you can see getting on to
the 2020s look different colors are
coming along uh look at that backs black
slides for one thing coal down to just
three percent by 2021 three percent as
you probably know now the main fuel is
gas that blue slice there 41 of our
power comes from gas but an ever
increasing proportion comes from
Renewables like wind and solar that's 13
and Rising
Down The Long Broad Avenue of the mall
towards the admiralty Arch the Queen's
procession moves slowly onward through
the crowds of cheering people who waited
to show their loyalty and their
affection
Her Majesty's Reign began in a dirtier
more polluted more industrialized
country it ends in one which is
transformed cleaner healthier longer
lived more diverse and more equal
where the quality of life may not be the
best in the world but it is much much
improved on decades gone by